- So, excited to have
Drew Houston in here,
very well known figure amongst
kind of our team out here.
And for those who are maybe
watching this video later,
founder of Dropbox, how many
how many billions of people
do have using?
I know, it's more like
hundreds of millions only.
- 300 million.
- And only 300 million people
- using it file sharing what
we'll talk more about that.
But, the way I view these things,
it's definitely for our
team to kind of meet
and talk to really interesting
people in Silicon Valley
and beyond but also for
kind of just the general
Khan Academy user base out
there to kind of get exposure
to really interesting people
in Silicon Valley and beyond.
And with that lens, I always
think of kind of myself
when I was 12 or 13 years old
and when I used to watch
like Johnny Carson,
and I always used to wonder, like,
how do you know who are these people?
How do they do that, like
what about like major in
in order to become that person.
And so I kind of want to have
a little bit of that land.
So I'll start there.
When you were a kid,
kind of what did you see
yourself doing or becoming?
And how did you try to set that up?
- So my path started
when I was really little.
So my my parents had PC Junior.
So my very first computer
when I was really little.
So first I would just
play computer games on it
but a couple years later,
when my dad got showed me
how there's a thing on
the computer called Basic.
And so I was lucky, they
showed me how to write
so my first lines of code and
I was like a really little.
- Like how little?
- I was five.
- That's good.
- Yeah my son needs to get in line.
(laughs)
- And it turns out,
when you're little like
that you have a lot of
free time on your hands.
And so, I was always like
playing on the computer
and I really loved playing games.
And so that was actually why
I want to learn programming
is to learn how to make
games, how these things worked
and like I want to insert
of my exploration of
how the computer worked,
I would figure out like,
oh, there's like this...
There's like files
and like, okay then when I save a game.
Like I can go into that file
and like give myself like 32,767 lives,
it's like, all these
little things like that.
- And if only I could
access this file from home
and kindergarten.
- Moving this floppy drive around, yeah.
So I thought it was
gonna be computer games.
That was what I would does
was interested in beginning
as then as far as a job
I start up babysitting,
- Really?
- So I was very good at it
like watching I was like 12 near 11
and like I would, the parents would leave
I put the kids to bed.
And I like as regular watching like HBO
and like, this is like a requirement.
I can only like babysit for, like,
families that had like
good TV and like Pringles
and things like that.
- Then if they didn't
do that is a red flag,
or your focal point was their cable.
- Exactly.
And then like, trying to like.
And then sometimes I'd be
like watching something
probably, like I shouldn't be watching.
They'd be like, shooting
or like bad words.
And I was very good like
listening from when the lock
went in there the key were in the lock.
- Oh yes.
- Anyway, this has nothing to
do with starting a company,
- Some time it will.
- But then I got a little
bit of an upgrade on
the job front, I was beta testing a game.
And an online game was maybe 14.
And they were taking
forever to build the game.
And so I started getting
restless and curious
and started poking around
under the hood of this game
and I found all these security holes.
I found all these vulnerabilities.
Anyway first you discover these things.
You're like, oh, my God, oh, my God.
I started impersonating,
like the developers
and things like that and sort of making
like a little bit of
trouble but then I'm like,
I sent him an email and
like guys you're really
you should fix this, you should fix this.
And you shouldn't have done this this way
you should have done this way.
And I'm like, really getting into it.
And they're like, well,
do you want to work here?
And so I ended up working
remotely as an engineer are like
they're like, do you
want to fix those bugs?
And I'm like okay.
And then this is the first
kind of startup adventure
first experience of many where my stock up
since we were worth nothing.
- Yes this 14 years old.
- That's 14.
- 14 years old.
- And this is part time remote
- but it was like a
cool thing to talk about
and like, biology class.
Anyway I had to get my dad to sign
all the employment paperwork
and things like that.
So, but that was the path of
this I was literally working on a game.
But then fortunately there as we learn
there's a lot of other things in life.
Beyond like, Unreal Tournament,
which are really interesting.
- Beyond what?
- Unreal Tournament or
Starcraft at apoint.
- Unreal Tournament yes that's it.
- That's a little later on, like
PC era was like more like
the Sierra games like
- Yes.
- Kiddy Quest
- for something that, you
guys weren't born yet.
- For me it was Pong.
- Okay.
- Yeah, that was I'm a little older.
- We're losing up.
(laughs)
- Yes I'm little bit we
have a little overlap.
And then you go to MIT
many of us have been there as well.
And I watched your commencement speech.
(audience laughs)
I watched your commencement
speech, which was great.
It helped that the guy before
you really set a new low
in terms of commencement speech quality,
but your speech was really I thought,
a really powerful speech.
And I think it kind of
hit this issue of like
you didn't plan on being,
Drew Houston to Dropbox founder,
but you did think you were
gonna be an entrepreneur.
I mean, it seems like
while you were in college,
you were constantly
thinking about starting
a business of some kind.
- Yes, and your speech was great, too.
- I wasn't fishing for that.
- No no it was.
- It feels good though,
- I like it.
- You're sort of like,
- there's no instruction
manual for these things
I'm like, you start like
googling excessively for
like every commencement
speech ever given before.
Anyway, so but no, I did plan to be...
I always was excited about doing something
that was my own thing, whether
it's making a computer game.
And originally, as I
learned more about business
and starting a company I
was always just turned out
that I joined startups as an
engineer or like an intern,
when I was little, and then
just didn't never really left.
- And you just keep doing
that while you were in college
I mean, you already had
that kind of experience.
- Yeah.
- So you're starting stuff.
Like when your freshman year, summer year,
were you doing stuff?
- So the the game company unfortunately
folded pretty quickly.
But that then give me that experience
and let me get a job at a local company.
There's another startup
but it was kind of an MIT founders,
so there's kind of a relation there.
But yeah, and the summers
I would taking classes
and then every summer I would go work at
first couple years of just the company
that I worked at in high school.
So they are like maybe, half hour away,
half hour outside of Boston.
- Yeah and the one thing
that I think is mysterious
for everyone and even
sometimes when people ask me
I don't have a clear answer
'cause it's still a
little bit mysterious is
how do you stumble on this thing
that just kind of takes off
like wildfire that just...
And you have an interest right man,
you actually started kind
of a little bit closer
to kind of what we do here
kind of your first startup
which I think you
started your junior year?
- Yeah.
- Was around SAT it was called accolade.
- Right?
So my, you never know where
these things are gonna go.
'Cause I mean, I think anybody
who grows up programming
or whether it's programming
or something else,
like there's always tinkering with things
it's all just one project after another.
And for and then the first
one I want to start a company
I took my junior year off from MIT.
So I took it took a year leave,
which ended up being a
really great experience.
And I promised my parents
I would come back and I did
but so the SAT at the time was changed,
there was like all this
change happening right.
There emerging in the writing section,
it's going from 1600 to 2400.
Now, I know there's all kinds
of other stuff happening.
But this was back in the day where
to study for the SAT,
you'd have to show up at
some like horrible classroom
and like eight in the
morning on a Saturday
to listen to some like 17 year old
who didn't want to be there either.
And all it was just reading out of a book.
Like this was the state of
the art in like SAT prep
and we're like guys like the internet.
It's not like the internet
as been here for like
a little while, it's like it's
been here for a long time.
And why are we still, it's
like how my parents studied
for the SAT.
And so I teamed up with actually
one of my former teachers
from high school and we
started building a new kind of
course an online course for
the what was then the new SAT.
- And what's your lesson I
mean, what 'cause you too,
I guess not do that at some point
but you worked on it for some time.
You did.
- It was interesting.
So I started working on 'cause I'm like,
here's like an opportunity.
Here's something that my
Co-founder and I knew really well.
I mean, I just, I don't know,
I treated the SAT...
Like one of the things I
really like to do is like
reverse engineer, like how
things work, take things apart.
So whether that's, more
typical stuff like the kind of
tinkering that kids do, or like
the finding all the security
problems in that game.
When I start working on the
SAT like I had to study for it,
I was like, how does this thing work?
And so you can as yo know
they're always like little tricks
and little patterns you
can take advantage of
and I'm like, okay, the only
the really hard thing about
the verbal section is the vocab
'cause like you can, in
general you can teach someone
how to do a sentence completion
without really teaching him
it's the words that are hard.
So, when I was 16, I
wrote all this software
to do kind of flashcards
and adapt and remember
which ones I was getting right
and which ones I was getting wrong
and things like that, 'cause
I didn't want it was too lazy
to like cut out all the paper flashcards
and I'm like this is so stupid.
And so I had done that code
actually was kind of on
the shelf for five years.
And then and then when the SAT changed
and I had a friend of
mine, who was a teacher
who had his own SAT course.
And we had this whole shtick going
I was at MIT, he had
graduated from Harvard,
like as a result of all this
like reverse engineering
SAT and studying a lot for
I got to 1600.
So I was like, we had all
like the boxes checked
for the parents and we're
like, we know how this works.
So that it was really
just seeing an opportunity
and being like, you
don't attach too much of
an outcome around it.
Like I didn't have a goal,
like I need to make this
much money or whatever,
it's sort of like another
interesting project.
And probably the best
part of that was really
just having an excuse to learn about
business in like a rigorous way.
So and what I mean a rigorous
way I mean like I didn't know
anything about sales
or marketing or finance
or like any of these subjects
and they all seem very
like remote and mysterious
and so to combat this I
would just go on Amazon
and type in like sales and then like find
like the top three rated
or most popular sales books
and just like read them and repeat that.
- And you find that valuable?
- Like reading.
- And it's super useful.
- Okay, reading is like
one of the probably
the most important, reading
my business is probably
the most important thing
that's prepared me for running Dropbox.
- And then what was it and
you talk a little bit about
it in your commencement speech
but I find this transition is kind of
the most interesting one is
you were working on this
for two years I think
in through graduation.
What kind of you know, as hard
as you're told to persevere
and keep working on
something don't give up
but at some point, maybe you are kind of
putting good time after bad.
- Yeah.
It was super interesting at
the beginning 'cause like
and when you first get to work,
you get down to such an
important orders of business of
like, all right.
I got to Photoshop a logo
and print out business cards
as a founder on them
and other very important
and then hand them out to people
so that they know that I'm a founder now,
it's like this is like the stuff you.
- And I still do that.
(laughs)
- But then, what you realize
is after that kind of
after you're like Incorporated
and you get your like
facts back from the
Delaware Secretary of State,
and these things all seem
very official and important.
After you're like, day number 74 of like
I gotta take out the trash.
Like we got to erase the whiteboard
and like all this.
You're like actually,
this is a lot of work.
And which it was good, but...
So I think with my first company,
neither of us knew what
we were doing at all
and so we're bootstrapping it.
And there's just a lot of kind
of manual labor around like
we were too cheap to get like employees.
(laughs)
And we didn't have any money.
So, who's gonna write the
math questions is like me
and I just still remember
having to like force myself
to like write these math questions
and draw these diagrams
and be like, all right,
so where did the train
leave from last time?
Okay, this train leaves, Sacramento
and so I'm like, God,
at some point honestly,
I can't do this.
- We have people who do that.
So it's actually quite fun to do that.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Seriously I find that I do.
- And so but today.
(audience laughs).
I feel your pain.
(laughs)
No, no,
but the problem wasn't really the work
it was just more like we're
putting a lot of effort into it
and not seeing a lot of return.
So it was for me, it wasn't
it's kind of lost some of
the variety of the work.
And so I just got kind of...
It just became harder and harder.
I felt like I had to push myself
like so much like it.
And, it just became something I dreaded,
it became something where
I'd have to trick myself into
like making progress.
And I'm like, and then I start,
it's this like negative spiral, right?
'Cause you're like, you
start resenting the work,
you start getting mad at yourself
'cause you're like why am
I not more disciplined?
Your like, why is like
why and it's just like,
then which makes you present it even more
and thinks there's something
wrong with yourself
like all this like stuff in your head.
And then what happened was,
I had a friend of mine,
who started a company and did things
a little bit more properly,
like he had a Co-founder
who he's like, really good friends with.
They raise money, they could
just set up the company
like a good normal company
and then they were just having a blast.
They were Working every waking hour
but like there was having
fun like every minute
this is what it looked like and felt like.
And so I was like, at
first I'm like oh man
maybe I'm really defective.
Like look, these guys are
having no problem with this.
But then what happened
was I actually started
I would find these little side projects
and I start working on a poker bot.
Again, reverse engineering
like people said this is impossible
I'm like it as possible.
And so I was really good at the security
and kind of reverse engineering part of it
and could do enough of the
AI but it was like this,
I was just possessed.
Like, I would be like
dragging my computers
around everywhere.
Like my parents would ask had
me come up to New Hampshire
'cause we like a little place
like this place on a lake
where you're like, supposed
to get away from technology the next thing
I'm like putting like
three monitors on like
the kitchen stove 'cause
there's not enough room
and like working on this thing.
And so but it turned out
I mean, you never know
how these things are
gonna sort of all line up.
But then when I was working
on I was still working on
the SAT prep company and my friend Adam
who I mentioned moved
out to San Francisco.
And next thing I know he's
two years younger than me
but the next phone call I get from him,
he's like, hey, I've raised
five million dollars.
And like, I was like
that's a lot of money.
Like that number has
like two commas in it,
like what the hell.
And this is like,
my little brother in our
fraternity I'm like, oh, my God.
And so, but it just
turned out that in part
it was sort of the setup was there, like
I really loved algorithms
and distributed systems
and I studied computer science
and like, these are my favorite things.
And so it sort of sort of fertile ground.
And then, one time I lost,
I left my thumb drive at home
and so I couldn't get any
work done for my company.
And the sort of non PR, like
the director's cut version of
sort of the Dropbox origin story.
So as taking a ride on the Chinatown Bus,
the Fung Wah from from Boston in New York
and I left my thumb drive behind
and I'm just like, I hate I'm like
what do you do in these situations
that you're like, Oh,
I hate my thumb drive.
I'm like, I hate myself.
I'm so like, stupid.
I'm so disorganized,
like I keep doing this,
why can't I be better and
just the self flagellation.
And that's like, there's
nothing else to do
for like four and a half hours
but but I had this three gigabyte
Linux virtual machine image,
they need to keep in sync
across all these computers.
'Cause I have worked
on a laptop sometimes,
sometimes a desktop,
sometimes another computer
and like nothing, there are
a million things that claim
to solve this problem and
none of them actually did.
And so it was really personal frustration
that led me to open up the editor
and start writing some code
that eventually turned into Dropbox.
Although I had no idea that
would be the case at that time.
- And I mean, I think this
is an important moment
because a lot of times
when you read about Dropbox
you say, oh, yeah, he
had the idea of having
sharing files across multiple devices
and all that but whenever
I realized now that
what's amazing isn't the idea
is that you very old idea,
in fact, almost anyone
who's worked on data storage
or anything has for the last 40 years.
has been trying to do this.
And so to me the power of
or almost the audacity of
what is this was like a big problem
that a lot of really smart
people had kind of tried to do
as you mentioned maybe
even launch companies on it
didn't have really complete solutions.
What was kind of going on in your head
that convinced you that know, like,
I think the past that I'm
about to take on this problem
is going to be the one that works.
- Well, it was just so clear from trying
all the other things that like,
all like 100 things that
claim to solve this on paper
but in like in practice,
they never really worked.
And there at school at MIT,
they have that you sometimes
you like a campus network
or an sort of hardcore
Unix kind of way of solving
this problem, but like
for a Windows computer
or like a MacBook like there's
just you're stuck carrying
around a thumb drive and
emailing yourself stuff
and that was your point I was more just
amplify the frustration.
I'm like, guys, this is not a new idea.
We've thought about this is like the 60s
like why does hell am I
forced to do this like
really made me upset.
And then, there's some
conviction of it like,
look that the problem with
like the online drives
is like these very
specific technical things
where it's like it's all a big hack where
the way the online drive the
AI drives and extra drives
and for every letter there's been a drive
for all of them that they all worked on
the same basic principle
which was like, okay,
we're gonna trick your applications
and operating system into
thinking that instead of like,
when a program write
something to the disk,
instead of running it to the
disk on the inside the laptop
it actually intercepts it
sends it over to the internet
to server somewhere and gets it back.
So, at first glance like
this is a great idea
will work with everything
it's not that hard.
But the problem is, you're
sent like if the server is
100 milliseconds away,
instead of five milliseconds
away like your hard drive or less.
Then you get all these
inexplicable problems
because like millions of millions
of millions lines of code
are all written with assumption
that this thing is like
five, 10 milliseconds away.
And I'm going into detail on this,
but it just like this there's like no way
you can ever make that work.
Like it's just like laws of physics
and so you need a completely
different approach.
And sort of a hybrid where like, okay,
you have big and cheap
and fast storage locally
and on a server it's but
it's like two swimming pools
connected by a straw, right?
And so first use the straw well,
and two like make it so that,
you're not waiting for the swimming pool
to make it back and forth.
Like, use it efficiently do
that in the background syncing
right, so.
And then it just turned
out no one had gotten
the technical part, right.
But then there's also like a user
there's like a design piece
of like how do you design
the interface, how do you make this.
What's a metaphor that
people can understand.
And then there's like
an academic piece of it
which like the algorithms
and how do you move the files
around and things like
that and store them.
But then there's like
a lot of grungy kind of
operating systems work.
Where how do you make it so that you work,
the fat 32 file system.
Every other file system
when it stores in the next
to the name of the file it stores like
when the file was modified.
And it's a timestamp and its
resolution of one second.
There's actually more
detailed now but just listen.
And then he likes just randomly
some random operating system
some some random hard drive
you can have a fat 32,000 that's stores
that modification time with
a resolution to two seconds.
And it's like, none of
the other ones do that
but that one does.
And suddenly, there's
all this weird complexity
to the code or like Windows
XP Service Pack three,
there be bugs were like
the Swedish version of that
not the Norwegian version, the
Swedish version of this way
and we're just like
cause Dropbox to crash.
And so part it says two things.
One is a fundamentally different approach
from what some of the other guys are doing
and then two is the a lot
of just like that kind of
obsession like the same thing,
the same way I was like obsessed with like
making a very well crafted
like SAT question about
quadrilateral and making
the diagram look like
the actual list is like
that then obsessing
over making really fast, reliable
and fixing that obscure
bug with Swedish windows.
- And when did you realize this,
you start on this you see a problem,
you start tackling and it is
an audacious problem to tackle.
What did you say, this is real this is
like I have a solution here.
Like this is already better
than what's out there industry.
- So first was when I just made something
that worked for myself.
And I'm like, I could actually use it
like I would put save something
and it would like show
up on my other computer
and I'd be like, finally.
And then but it really
started to take shape
once I made a video a
demo video of Dropbox
like a three minute little
it's it's still online somewhere
or you can find it.
And I put it on Hacker News.
There's this new site for startups
and it just got a ton of it
was like top of Hacker News
for like two days.
Like, these are the old days
so it was easier to do that.
But that gave me like, a ton of...
I mean, I'd already decided to quit my job
it's complicated.
So I just graduated, I
was working as an engineer
at a startup and I was
moonlighting on my SAT prep thing
that was the other thing.
So like you're asking why,
like why did I kind of get frustrated.
It's like we my Co-founder
wasn't gonna quit his job
I wasn't really either.
The thing was never
really going to succeed
but also wasn't gonna die.
So like it just got kind of frustrating
But anyway, so Dropbox really
the first real turning point
was when I put the video up
and then Arash my Co-founder
saw it on Hacker News,
like a week later, we got
introduced through mutual friend.
So I got a Co-founder from it, Paul Graham
Arash my Co-founder and
then our first investor
Paul Graham saw the video
and emailed me saying
'cause we just I just
applied solo to Y Combinator
with the idea.
- And that's one for this
was your second interaction
with Paul Graham.
- I had a complicated series
of interactions before.
So Y Combinator is kind of
like a planet college, right?
Lots of people want to
get in not enough spots,
you have this very competitive dynamic.
And so actually, the sort
of admission system was
how I thought about
getting into Y Combinator.
And so I had actually been
flown out to California
to hang out with some other
Y Combinator founders.
And I also want to pitch Paul on Dropbox.
And so I showed up at Y
Combinator a little early
before one of the dinners
and walked into his office
and asked if I could show him Dropbox
and he was very angry about that,
visitors are not welcome.
But the problem with that is like imagine,
we all remember playing the school.
Imagine having like five minutes
with like the dean of admissions
and the one thing that
they learn is that like,
you're an asshole.
(all laughs)
All right.
I know I'm so--
- No that's cool yeah, we keep it real.
- Sorry to all the 12
year olds watching this
- don't say that.
- Yes.
- But that first video was like huge
in terms of getting started.
- Yeah and then you get started
and I mean, and what
year was this was 2007?
- 2007.
- And then it's just been kind of...
I mean, I actually I don't
think I've ever seen it.
I mean you guys have got to
be one of the fastest growing
organizations maybe in
the history of the Valley.
- Also, it's been growing quickly.
I don't either they're all
like people are setting
all kinds of records these days
but but the company in terms of headcount
has grown really fast.
And then the user base has
grown from 2009 we're like
a million users now we're over 300.
- And I mean, what are your,
kind of in in hindsight are
now that you can look over
the last seven years.
I mean, what it been
and I almost view this
we were talk a little bit about this one
before we did this is
what would you have told yourself
when you if it was an 80% organization
or 90% organization that to kind of
like either ease your
stress or let you know
that something's coming or
ways to manage it as you grow?
- Well, I think there's a lot
and it's hard to kind of
boil it down to, like pithy,
like phrases of like oh, this
is how you build a company.
It's like how do you play basketball?
Like I wanted to take a
while to explain, right?
So, but I think the...
I don't really know how to play
I'm not very good at basketball.
- I am, but I'm not I'm kidding.
- Alright.
So what I would say is,
some of the earliest
most helpful advice that we got was really
to focus on the people we
brought into the company
like make sure everybody's
like really, really talented.
Like, that's probably the best like hack
you can do to make everything
else easier, right?
'Cause, put a good person
between you and all your problems
right.
And our angel investors and
some early folks were like,
there's kept drilling that into our heads
like make sure the talent bar
is really high be very choosy.
And I think just sort of an attitude
of really trying to systematically train
to like, understand like, okay, well,
here's what I'm dealing with today
but I'm gonna talk to people
who are maybe six months ahead,
a year ahead, five years ahead.
And like what are they dealing with?
I asked as quick as I
was talking to their CEO
eight thousand person company.
I'm like, all right, we're
approaching 1000 people
at Dropbox.
What am I going to see between 1000, 2001?
What should I watch out for?
Like what would you put in place now,
so that as you've done all these things
and grown the company.
What do you wish you could do today?
So a lot of what I do is
sort of think about that
and sort of all you have to
be able to see around corners
and one way to do that is reading.
One way to do that is having
mentors and getting advice.
And then the other the thing
that gives you some calm is
that what you read on TechCrunch
or in the press generally.
When someone tells a story of a company,
they're like, oh, yeah
Dropbox it started out
with not a lot of users then
later they had a lot of users
and they did great.
(audience laughs)
And they just have this sort of this like
this narrative arc that they just,
they're like well the real truth is
this complicated stuff happened?
And this was actually really hard.
They're like yeah, no, okay.
Two kids, two MIT kids in
a dorm room have an idea
they've been...
And so, the truth is like
it's actually very complicated
and hard but that all
kind of gets glossed over
but when when you read like profiles
there's a lot of books that
have been written about
their lately that the
everything store is a book about
Amazon it's a great book.
Steve Jobs biography,
Google, Apple, Microsoft,
Facebook, all these Intel like Oracle.
Like I've read as much as
many kind of profiles on
tech companies and other companies
as I could get my hands on
over these companies have
last a few decades.
And what you learn is that
there's enough that once
you sort of look behind
the curtain there's nothing
that's that magical.
And that's important
for people to understand
because you may think like oh,
I don't know anything about business.
So I should just go like not,
I'm never gonna be good at it
because I've never been good at it.
And that's just something
as I should go get
like a business guy or
person like to do that stuff
'cause I'll never be good at it
but it's actually something you can learn.
And so I think that
mindset of like in a week
you can probably limited
in terms of what you can do
but like think about playing an instrument
or becoming a doctor like any these things
it's like all of us can realize like yeah,
it's a lot of work but I can
sort of see a path from A to B.
Turns out like most things
you want to learn have
that kind of potential,
whether it's public speaking
or building a company
or any of those things
if you have the attitude that like that
and you give yourself time
like you can actually pick these things up
there's nothing that magical about them.
So and that's one thing
from these profiles.
And then the other thing 'cause
you see in the early days
they make all these like really crazy
stupid mistakes and
like do all these things
that are like really, really wrong.
And then that's also
therapeutic is like you realize
all these companies
were like a total mess.
And actually, I see Albert in the corner
Albert is early Dropboxer.
Albert can tell you how what
a mess really Dropbox was.
And so what you read about
is actually not reflective of reality.
It's a much mess here
and kind of less glamorous process.
- Yeah and I'm about to open
it go into some questions
that from the team but
just my last question is
where do you see kind of
Dropbox in five, 10, 50 years,
the end of your life what do
you hope Dropbox has done?
- 50 years.
I don't know if anybody's made it's like
self driving boats yet.
- That would be an innovation.
- I mean, you can't
really look that far out,
but we've realized and
what we we talk a lot about
is we have this opportunity
where now we have a lot of resources,
a lot of really talented people,
we can solve these really big problems.
And then what we're really
working on is building this home
for everybody is most
important stuff, right?
'Cause you think about
your house 20 years ago
like you'd walk into your house
it'd be like, you know mail on the table
you'd go in your living room,
all your photos are on your kitchen,
your photos are on your
refrigerator, right?
And you go down the hall
and your briefcase has
like your documents
and like all that stuff
is now on servers or in your Dropbox.
And so we need this like new kind of home.
So we we think all the time about like
how can we save hundreds of
millions of people from like
these things are really painful
and annoying about technology.
Like all these little paper
cuts like forgetting your thumb
like the equivalent of like these little
thumb drive problems are
like everywhere, right?
And so how do we find the biggest ones
and solve them at massive scale.
And so and then,
specifically we started out
with this app that you
put on your computer
or your phone that gives you
this like Dropbox folder.
But really what you want is
what you're using that folder for is often
you're putting photos in there.
You're getting work done,
you're collaborating
with other people.
And so we were, we're
starting to dig into some of
those use cases, a little more things.
Like we just launched a
photo app called Carousel,
which is like if the
gallery on your phone had
like every picture you've ever taken.
And if you could text
like 100 or 1000 photos
and videos at a time.
That's what Carousel lets you do,
for some reason that had
not really existed or no one
like everybody has this
problem just no one solved it.
- Yeah awesome. So I'll go
into some of these questions.
The first one this is this is from Marcia,
you can raise your hand
Marcia if you're here.
Where is Marcia?
I don't know, where is Marcia?
- [Woman] She training remotely.
- Oh, she's remotely.
So what's your typical workday like?
- Probably the biggest thing
I spend time on is recruiting.
And so there's, often there'll
be some kind of fire drill
at night where it's like,
okay we're acquiring a company
or there's some candidate
and we're fighting
with Google or some
startup to try to get them,
there's a tug of war.
And like I'm often
finding myself down here
like gone big game hunting
for people to join Dropbox.
So I'll be like in the Google campus
or if you see me in one of this companies
you know what I'm doing.
(audience laughs)
And so recruiting is the biggest thing.
And then the probably
the next biggest thing
is just meetings some small numbers
with people on my team
around certain projects.
So every six months, we
pick like a dozen things
that are really important
that we wanna get done
and then I'll be spending time
with them like, okay, here's
this, here's a new stuff
we're gonna do in collaboration
answering questions like
that, what is Dropbox?
Like what should it be in five years?
What will it be in 50 years?
And what kind of place
do we want to create
and then there's this
is much longer tail of
all kinds of other stuff
or there is like partners
or customers or just other things.
- Yeah.
- It's a hard question
to answer succinctly.
- Yeah, that's pretty good.
I'm just show up at the--
- I had I made something that downloads
my Google Calendar and
I wrote Python script
that downloads my Google
Calendar into Excel spreadsheet
and like triage is my time.
- [Khan] Automatically?
- Well it's not you have to supervise,
you have to triage stuff or
you have someone help you
triage other stuff.
but then I had these like
rolling charts of like
how I spent the last week
or the last four weeks
or the last 12 weeks.
'Cause a lot of people say--
- That's a product I'll use that.
- All right.
- That's interesting you get
data analytics on your time.
That's good.
- It is, it's super important.
So I did that more.
Like one of the most
important things you need
to think about like as your
job gets more complicated
there's just more stuff
competing for your time.
It's really important
understand where it goes
that's a book called
The Effective Executive by Peter Drucker,
it's like any book on management
will like focus on that.
So, but there's another thing
is like no one's created
a tool where you can see
where your time goes.
It's like everybody, a lot
of people have that problem.
So I have been at times very
like rigorous about that.
- Very cool.
And so I have a question from Dylan.
And Dylan is right over there.
So what are some of the most interesting,
unexpected, fun, technical challenges
that you and your team have
faced in the process of
scaling Dropbox to hundreds
of millions of users?
- So I think it's just fundamentally
the challenge of Dropbox itself.
I mean, we're trying to
build like the file system
for the internet.
And so how do you connect
a billion devices, right.
And so that comes along with all kinds of
technical challenges where
people are saving a billion files
every day on Dropbox.
And so, that's more than
there are Tweets on Twitter.
And this is not like Little
hundred, 40 characters
it's like you're like wedding photos.
- Pictures yeah.
- You connect nothing, you
can't have a bad day, right?
So even just the core service
but then as you branch
out then there's all these
interesting things with,
how do we make a...
There's sort of far afield
things like computer version
like how do we infer photos or something
you may how do we organize
your photos for you.
Search.
Pretty much every kind of
lay like client software,
we have big data, we have data science,
we have a bunch of infrastructure stuff.
Every permutation,
every possible platform.
If people are like really
into like hardcore algorithms
we need like that.
If we have people really deep into systems
we like unlimited need for
that much storage stuff.
I mean, it's really all over the map like
it feels like any permutation
of technical challenge.
We have it at least in Software.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And I think we have time for one more.
So this from Joel.
Where is Joel?
There is Joel right there.
So he'd like to hear about Hack Week.
And this is where we've
had a little bit of
we want to do more of this.
How did it get started
and has any what new stuff
has come out of it?
Has anything actually been privatized?
- And so Hack Week is basically
something we do every year
where you guys have probably
heard of a hackathon
or do like a one day hacking event
but we're like all right,
let's take this to 11
we'll do a whole week.
And because sometimes
Dropbox would have been hard
to prove that in a day but
actually the first prototype
had something reasonably
working in a week.
And so it's something we do, really,
to sort of get back to the
spirit of like where we started
where there are no constraints.
A lot of people were telling us that
what we were doing was...
A lot of investors told me that Dropbox
it's a stupid thing to get into have a yet
another storage company or all
the other ones that failed.
But like it just doesn't
matter like instead of
like talking or debating
like actually write code
and just if you do it
right, like you can change
how people think.
And so a ton of things have
made it into the products
from having to account having a personal
and business account and
Dropbox that was a huge project
that started out as a Hack Week project.
One of my Hack Week projects was the new
and the way you do notifications
are like those sort of
the menu bar and Dropbox
is not like the native
and then you can see like what's changed
and have a different UI around that.
Things like a bunch of security stuff.
So two factor authentication was something
that started there a lot
of how you can like rewind
your files or undo things
that was at Hack Week project.
And then a lot of other stuff
which maybe didn't make it
one to one later like
make it pound for pound
into the product.
But even just like when
we watch people build
like all these apps on top of Dropbox
like that informed like someone made
like a Jukebox kind of music
player as a separate app
and it just sort of like plants a seed
that may manifest itself years
later in something like oh,
well now instead of just
having the Dropbox app,
you have all family of apps.
Like Carousel , Mailbox, Dropbox.
So that it's really just a time for A
just to work on anything except
what you're supposed to be working on.
B like kind of unleash
people and remember kind of
like lift the constraints of day to day.
And three it's to change
how people think about
if you have an idea like prove it
and you learn as people
have like a lot of really
this is pretty amazing group of people
we have in the company.
Where the interns like take Dropbox
and put it put it in a weather balloon
and put an Android phone into space
where that this phone
will be taking pictures of
the ride up and down.
And so they're just crazy.
It was just have this like pictures,
uploading the Dropbox of like space.
- Well, I just want to thank you.
I think I speak for everyone here
that it's been a real treat to kind of
get to know you just now.
So thank you very much.
- Okay thanks awesome.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)